[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein herzhaftes Rezept.
Ich werde nämlich eine bosnische Pita
und eine bosnische Bureka machen.
Im Prinzip...
Das ist jetzt so ein Balkanrezept.
Aber im Prinzip sind türkische Rezepte,
bosnische Rezepte, bulgarische Rezepte,
griechische Rezepte
oftmals sehr ähnlich,
weil ja alles auch so ein bisschen
aus dem Osmanischen Reich alles so abstammt.
Aber ich will gar nicht so sehr
in die Tiefe der Geschichte gehen.
Denn jeder sagt dann immer:
"Nein! Das ist unser Rezept!"
"Nein, das ist unseres!"
Ich mache heute einfach ein herzhaftes, leckeres Rezept.
Und zwar habe ich das Rezept
von meiner bosnischen Freundin, von Lejla,
beziehungsweise von ihrer Mama, von der Fikreta.
Und die Pita, die ist vegetarisch.
Die mache ich gleich mit Schichtkäse
und zeige euch aber gleich,
wie ihr die fleischige Variante machen könnt,
das Burek,
Bureka.
Heißt es jetzt Burek oder Bureka?
Mh.
Ihr könnt es ja mal in die Kommentare schreiben.
Das Rezept ist übrigens auch
super für den Ramadan geeignet.
Denn ihr könnt es ganz toll vorbereiten.
Ihr könnt auch, wenn ihr sagt,
Mensch, ich mache mir jetzt auf einmal die Arbeit,
mache an einem Tag einfach vier bis fünf Böreks
beziehungsweise Pitas,
nämlich die vorbacken.
Also diese erste Backzeit nutzen
und dann ganz gut auskühlen lassen
und einfrieren.
So könnt ihr dann nämlich bei Bedarf
das Pita auftauen im Backofen,
noch mal übergießen mit der Flüssigkeit
– erzähle ich euch später –
und dann einfach zum Ramadan zum Iftar-Abend,
also zum Fastenbrechen, servieren.
Oder auch,
wenn ihr jetzt keinen Ramadan-Monat habt bei euch,
dann könnt ihr das einfach so vorbereiten
und habt immer Börek und Pita auf Vorrat.
Und der Teig ist wirklich ein supereinfacher Teig!
Ihr braucht dafür nämlich nur zwei Zutaten,
nämlich 500 Gramm Mehl
– da habe ich ein ganz normales Weizenmehl, das 405er –
und 300 Gramm Wasser.
Und dieser Teig wird ganz dünn wie so eine Art Filoteig.
Und dafür braucht ihr nicht mal einen besonderen Ausrollstab.
Denn das Ganze funktioniert dann auf einer Tischdecke.
Auf Türkisch heißt dieses Börek-Rezept auch Çarşaf Böreği.
Also, wie gesagt,
ähnlich.
Ich mache jetzt erst mal den Teig.
Dafür braucht ihr die zwei Zutaten.
Entweder verknetet ihr jetzt einfach
das Mehl mit dem Wasser mit der Hand
oder eben in der Küchenmaschine.
Ich mache das jetzt hier ganz kurz.
Denn
so habe ich einfach die Hände frei.
[Musik]
Am Anfang kommt es einem so vor,
als wäre es zu wenig Wasser,
als würde sich der Teig nicht verbinden.
Und je nachdem, welches Mehl man hat,
braucht man auch etwas mehr oder weniger Wasser,
so einen Esslöffel.
Aber ihr seht hier schon, der Teig wird gut.
Aber er ist noch hier leicht klumpig.
Das heißt, ich muss den jetzt wirklich
noch ordentlich durchkneten,
dass er sich gut vermischt
und wirklich schön glatt wird ohne Klumpen.
Mit der Hand ist es natürlich ein bisschen schwieriger
beziehungsweise einfach ein bisschen kraftaufwendiger.
Aber, wenn ihr das so macht,
dann habt ihr schon mal ein schönes Work-out.
[Musik]
Der Teig ist jetzt fertig.
Wie ihr sehen könnt, richtig schön geschmeidig.
Und ich habe jetzt auch wirklich
kein Wasser mehr dazugegeben.
Das waren einfach die 300 Milliliter.
Und der muss jetzt ein bisschen ruhen,
damit er entspannen kann.
So wie der Murat ab und zu.
Also gebe ich ihn hier in die Schüssel,
decke ihn ab
und zeige euch jetzt schon mal,
wie ich die vegetarische Füllung mache.
Und diesen Teig werde ich jetzt aber noch mal zubereiten.
Das heißt, ich habe dann zweimal 500 Gramm Menge,
damit ich eben einmal die vegetarische
und einmal die fleischige Variante machen kann.
Für die vegetarische Füllung nehme ich
500 Gramm Schichtkäse,
drei Eier,
zwei Esslöffel Öl,
– das ist ein Sonnenblumenöl –
eineinhalb Teelöffel Salz und etwas Pfeffer,
150 Gramm Naturjoghurt, einen 3,5%igen,
150 Gramm Tulum Käse
– da sage ich gleich was dazu –
und zum Übergießen brauche ich noch 200 Gramm Sahne.
Ich benutze jetzt, glaube ich, sogar zum ersten Mal
in meinen Videos Schichtkäse.
Deswegen zeige ich euch hier noch mal die Packung.
Schichtkäse ist einfach ein 10%iger Käse
ähnlich wie Quark.
Wenn ihr den jetzt nicht findet, könnt ihr auch Quark nehmen,
wobei der ein bisschen anders schmeckt.
Also Quark hat so diesen quarkigen Geschmack.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich es anders beschreiben soll.
Und Schichtkäse eben ein bisschen anders.
Den gibt es aber auch in jedem Supermarkt.
Und hier habe ich noch den Tulum Käse.
Das ist ein Nomadenkäse.
Der erinnert so ein bisschen an Schafskäse und Hirtenkäse,
ist aber von der Struktur her etwas anders.
Und den Tulum dürft ihr aber nicht vergleichen
mit dem Tulum Käse, den ihr vielleicht
aus einem türkischen Dorf kennt.
Denn der Tulum Käse,
den mein Papa zum Beispiel immer mitgebracht hat
– legal natürlich.
Man darf ja eigentlich keine Käsesachen importieren.
Aber früher haben sie es halt mitgebracht.
Der schmeckt viel zu stark.
Und der wurde auch früher immer in so einem Fell zubereitet
und ich konnte es nie essen.
Aber der ist wirklich superlecker,
schmeckt wirklich wie so ein Schafskäse ganz mild.
Und der ist eben auch schon so bröckelig in der Konsistenz,
also jetzt nicht negativ, sondern eher positiv.
Und das habe ich jetzt selbst mit dazu gemacht.
Denn die Fikreta, die hat eigentlich
nur diese Schichtkäsekomponenten mit drin.
Und ich glaube,
das passt aber jetzt ganz gut dazu geschmacklich.
Also
die Füllung ist supereinfach in der Herstellung.
Ihr nehmt jetzt einfach alle Zutaten.
Die kommen hier rein.
Schichtkäse,
dann die Eier
zum Binden,
etwas Öl,
Salz und Pfeffer.
Ihr könnt auch gerne mit Zwiebeln würzen
oder etwas Lauch schneiden
oder einfach Kräuter nehmen.
Der Joghurt kommt hier auch rein.
Den Nomadenkäse auch noch mit rein.
Jetzt verrührt ihr einfach alles ganz kurz
und dann ist die Füllung schon mal fertig.
Und der Teig, der sollte schon
so etwa ein halbe Stunde lang ruhen dürfen.
Okay, Schneebesen war nicht die beste Wahl.
Dann verrühre ich es so einmal schnell.
Und während die Füllung jetzt hier
an der Seite schon mal stehen kann,
kann ich schon mal noch die Fleischfüllung zubereiten.
Und wie gesagt, bereite ich da einfach noch mal den Teig zu.
Nur, damit ihr wisst, für wie viel Menge
dann später eben auch der Teig gedacht ist.
Und die Sahne, die brauche ich gleich zum Übergießen.
Die kommt nicht in die Füllung.
Für die Fleischvariante brauche ich
500 Gramm Hackfleisch.
Da könnt ihr entweder Rinderhackfleisch nehmen
oder Rind und Lamm sogar gemischt.
Schmeckt auch richtig gut.
Eine Zwiebel,
50 Gramm Wasser.
Öl brauche ich jetzt hier nicht,
weil ja das Hackfleisch schon genügend Fett hat.
Und dann hier noch die Gewürze.
Da habe ich jetzt zwei Teelöffel Salz,
einen halben Teelöffel Pfeffer,
einen halben Teelöffel Majoran
und etwas Bergbohnenkraut.
Ja.
Im Prinzip muss ich jetzt hier nur
die Zwiebel ganz fein schneiden.
Ihr könnt auch gerne zwei Zwiebeln nehmen.
Ich glaube, ich nehme noch eine dazu,
weil die relativ klein ist.
Es soll ja schön würzig schmecken.
Und hier, aber auch bei der vegetarischen Version
darf die Füllung ruhig etwas
so ganz leicht versalzen schmecken.
Denn der Teig hat ja gar kein Salz drin.
Das heißt, da jetzt einfach keine Angst haben
und nicht zu wenig würzen.
Das gleicht sich dann später wirklich super aus.
[Musik]
Ich mag Zwiebel schneiden nicht.
Wisst ihr? Geschälte Kartoffeln gibt es im Glas.
Warum gibt es keine geschälten
und geschnittenen Zwiebeln für mich
für den Haushalt?
Nicht weinen, Sally.
Nicht weinen.
[Musik]
Ich glaube, der Trick bei Köchen ist einfach,
die Zwiebel so schnell zu schneiden,
dass der Dampf erst gar nicht dahin gelangt,
und dann ist sie schon verarbeitet.
Hach, Gott sei Dank!
Okay.
Und jetzt wird im Prinzip alles nur verrührt.
Also das Hackfleisch kommt jetzt hier auch rein.
Das Wasser brauche ich,
damit das Ganze nicht zu fest wird.
Hier noch die Zwiebeln.
Und die Kräuter.
Das Bergbohnenkraut muss ich noch ein bisschen zerkleinern.
Das habe ich nämlich aus dem Garten.
Das trockne ich dann immer.
Und, ich glaube, ich mache das jetzt einfach schnell so.
Und dann ist die Füllung hier auch bereit.
Und da gibt es aber auch Abwandlungen.
Also das ist jetzt nicht die einzige Füllung,
die es da gibt.
Ihr könnt auch wirklich was mit Lauch machen,
mit Spinat.
Ihr könnt da gerne in die Kommentare schreiben,
was so eure Lieblingsfüllung ist.
Jetzt nehmt ihr euch am besten
ein Baumwoll- oder Leinentuch,
eine Tischdecke zum Beispiel.
Manche nehmen auch ein Bettlaken.
Ich habe hier ein Tuch,
das benutze ich wirklich nur in der Küche.
Man sieht auch hier ganz deutlich,
hier habe ich schon ölige Flecken.
Hier wird gleich der Teig gezogen.
Aber zuerst einmal muss ich ihn hier ausrollen
und teile ihn jetzt schon mal in drei Portionen ein.
Ihr seht auch, der ist schön weich, aber er klebt nicht wirklich.
Jetzt einfach kurz dritteln.
Ihr könnt ihn auch vierteln.
Dann werden
eure Teige einfach etwas kleiner,
ist aber auch okay.
Die zwei, die ich jetzt nicht benutze,
lege ich solange wieder in die Schüssel zurück
und decke sie ab.
So trocknen sie nicht aus.
Und den ersten Teig rolle ich jetzt einfach mit Mehl aus
so weit, wie es geht mit dem Ausrollstab.
Ihr könnt auch hier, wenn ihr möchtet,
direkt ein Oklava nehmen, also so einen Holzstab.
Wartet. Den zeige ich euch.
Da hatte mein Papa einfach irgendwann
so einen Besenstiel genommen, einen sauberen,
und den einfach zugeschnitten.
Damit geht es auch einfach.
Aber ihr braucht trotzdem, auch wenn ihr ein Oklava besitzt,
später das Tuch.
Denn mit dem Tuch geht das Ganze noch ein bisschen dünner.
Hier rollt man es in der Mitte auf
und kann dann praktisch
durch so leichte Bewegungen nach außen streichen
und dann wird der Teig eben auch schön dünn.
Aber, wie gesagt, reicht da auch ein normaler Ausrollstab.
Wie bei so einem Aus-...
Wie bei so einem Apfelstrudel.
Jetzt klopfe ich hier das übrige Mehl ab,
lege den Teig hier rüber.
Hier wird er jetzt mit Öl bestrichen.
Und das sorgt gleich dafür, dass er elastisch wird
und sich schön ziehen lässt.
Und ich bestreiche da erst mal die Hälfte,
schlage es dann um
und so sind dann
alle Flächen schön gefettet.
Und das muss ich jetzt hier
so zwei, drei Minuten ruhen lassen.
Ich rolle jetzt auch schon mal den nächsten Teig aus.
Allerdings könnt ihr jetzt hier nicht viel vorbereiten
und nicht vorarbeiten.
Denn der Teig darf jetzt weder zu lange ruhen
noch zu kurz.
Ansonsten wird er einfach rissig.
Das kriegt man auch so mit der Zeit raus.
Und selbst, wenn es mal reißt, ist es auch nicht schlimm.
Aber ich lasse den jetzt hier so zwei, drei Minuten ruhen
und rolle hier den nächsten aus.
Den fette ich aber nicht,
sondern mache das dann wirklich ganz frisch vorher.
[Musik]
Ich fahre jetzt hier mit den Fingern unter den Teig,
ganz, ganz vorsichtig,
und ziehe den jetzt hier entlang.
Und ihr seht schon,
das Tuch hält dann praktisch den Teig fest.
Wenn ihr jetzt kein Tuch habt,
dann zieht der sich nämlich wieder zusammen.
Und die Struktur des Tuches hält ihn einfach schön fest.
Jetzt wirklich schön vorsichtig.
Gerne auch so über den Handrücken.
Wenn mal was löchrig wird, ist es auch nicht schlimm.
[Musik]
Und jedes Mal denke ich so:
"Mh. Der kann nicht mehr. Der kann nicht mehr."
Aber ihr seht schon, gerade hier der Rand,
den wirklich auch schön fein ziehen,
damit der nicht hart wird,
sondern eher ein bisschen knusprig wird.
Den halbiere ich jetzt hier einmal.
Und die Füllung, die könnt ihr euch jetzt so vorstellen.
Ich habe ja drei Teigklötze.
Also kann ich das hier
einmal halbieren und dann dritteln,
also in sechs Teile einteilen,
und hier schön gleichmäßig verteilen.
Wichtig ist, dass ihr jetzt auf die Länge das Ganze verteilt,
damit die Rolle gleichmäßig dick wird.
[Musik]
Und jetzt nehmt ihr einfach das Tuch zur Hilfe
und könnt es hier schön einschlagen
und zusammenrollen.
[Musik]
Und dann nehme ich hier jetzt schon mal
mein kleinstes Emailleblech.
Das fette ich jetzt so ein bisschen.
Bei der Größenangabe bin ich jetzt ein bisschen vorsichtig.
Denn meine Freundin hat es mir natürlich
so augenmaßmäßig gezeigt,
so ein bisschen hiervon, ein bisschen davon
und die Größe guckt man halt, wie es reinpasst.
Ich gucke jetzt einfach, dass ich die Menge bei euch für den,
also auf dem Blog richtig reinschreiben kann.
Ich denke jetzt nämlich, aus dem Bauchgefühl heraus
würde ich zwei kleine Bleche machen.
Aber vielleicht passt es auch in ein ganz großes Blech.
Könnt ihr dann selbst entscheiden.
Ich nehme jetzt hier die erste Rolle.
Die wickel ich jetzt hier schon mal auf.
Und ihr könnt jetzt entweder mehrere kleine machen
oder eine große.
Und die erste Rolle dann hier reinlegen.
Und die zweite lege ich dann hier drüber
beziehungsweise außenrum.
Ja.
Das kann jetzt kurz zur Seite.
Und dann geht es, wie gesagt,
mit dem nächsten Teig weiter.
[Musik]
Ojemine!
Also...
Oje, oje!
Also ein Teil kommt jetzt noch hier rein
und die anderen drei, die ich jetzt gleich forme,
ins nächste Blech.
So habe ich jetzt zwei
schöne, volle Bleche.
Und das Ende,
das kommt jetzt hier drunter.
Das sieht nämlich nicht ganz so schön aus.
Aber so gefällt mir es richtig gut.
Und so ist es auch schon bereit für den Backofen
Ich habe den bereits auf 200°C Ober-/Unterhitze vorbereitet
und vorgeheizt.
Und das wird jetzt so erst mal nicht bestrichen,
sondern wird gebacken
und nach etwa 20, 25 Minuten,
also nach der ersten Backzeit,
gieße ich dann die Sahne drüber
und die teile ich jetzt auch gleich auf
auf beide Bleche,
das heißt 100 Gramm pro Blech.
Und dann wird es noch mal fertig gebacken.
Und wie gesagt, könnt ihr das so erst mal vorbereiten
und backen
und nach dem Abkühlen einfrieren.
Und wenn ihr es dann frisch noch mal aufbacken wollt,
einfach erwärmen, Sahne drübergießen und servieren.
Das ist so der
Vorbereitungstrick.
So.
Ab mit dir in den Backofen
bei 200°C.
[Musik]
So. Die fleischige Variante macht ihr im Prinzip fast genauso.
Da verteilt ihr dann die Fleischfüllung hier.
Und die forme ich jetzt aber ein bisschen anders.
Dann habt ihr noch eine Variation.
Das werden jetzt kleine Schnecken.
Und hier auch darauf achten,
dass hier außen genug Füllung ist
und wirklich die Füllung gleichmäßig verteilt wird.
[Musik]
Es verschwindet.
Jetzt könnt ihr hier die Rolle nehmen
und einfach so kleine Schnecken machen,
hier abzupfen
und die dann gerne auch einzeln hier reinlegen.
[Musik]
Es darf noch fünf Minuten, bevor wir es drübergießen.
Denn jetzt ist es noch ein bisschen zu hell.
Ich warte jetzt noch, bis es ein bisschen Farbe hat,
und dann kommt erst die Sahne drüber.
Ich habe jetzt hier übrigens gerade umgebaut.
Denn für diese Variante
nehme ich jetzt einfach das größte Blech.
Ich denke, da passen gleich alle rein.
Dahinten ist das Nächste schon fertig,
kann ich schon mal weitermachen.
Und hier mache ich jetzt gleich alle rein.
So sieht es schon mal super aus.
Und jetzt, wie gesagt, 100 Gramm Sahne
pro Blech.
Was für ein Zungenbrecher!
Und das zieht jetzt schön ein,
macht es saftig und cremig.
Und kann jetzt noch fertig gebacken werden.
[Musik]
Mmh!
Guckt mal.
So sieht es perfekt aus!
Das hole ich jetzt raus
und dann wird es gleich mit Schmand serviert.
Und die Fleischvariante,
die braucht ihr gar nicht mit Sahne zu übergießen.
Denn die hat schon genug Eigenfett durch das Fleisch.
Und die wird später auch mit Schmand serviert.
Mit Schmand oder Joghurt.
[Musik]
Das Pita und Börek ist jetzt fertig.
Heute darf Daniel probieren.
>> DANIEL: Hi!
>> SALLY: Ja. Heute habe ich gebacken
einmal Börek, das ist mit Fleisch,
und einmal Pita, vegetarisch.
Ich muss sagen,
rein optisch gefällt mir das besser
als das.
>> DANIEL: Bin ich bei dir.
>> SALLY: Aber ich wollte es halt mal ausprobieren.
Denn man kann es auch so zubereiten.
Aber ich würde es nächstes Mal alles als Schnecke aufrollen.
Ja.
Probieren?
>> DANIEL: Gerne.
>> SALLY: Und wir servieren dazu Schmand.
Aber ihr könnt auch Joghurt nehmen.
>> DANIEL: Jetzt geht es los.
>> SALLY: Hast du so was schon mal gegessen?
>> DANIEL: Ich muss ehrlich sein. Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> DANIEL: Deswegen...
>> SALLY: Bei wem?
>> DANIEL: Bei meinem besten Freund bei der Mutter.
>> SALLY: Ah.
Oje. Da komm ich nicht dagegen an.
Gegen Mütter komme ich nicht an.
>> DANIEL: Türkische Hausmannskost. Aber...
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich glaube, ich muss so...
So in 15 Jahren bin ich irgendwann so die Mutti,
bei der alle essen.
>> DANIEL: Ich komm dann vorbei.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Probier es noch mal
in 15 Jahren.
>> DANIEL: Wir werden sehen.
>> SALLY: So.
Also, wenn du willst,
>> DANIEL: Mit Schmand?
>> SALLY: wie gesagt, kannst du mit Schmand. Das ist
>> DANIEL: Danke schön.
>> SALLY: so bosnisch dann.
Das stimmt!
>> DANIEL: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ich habe das Rezept von Fikreta
und von meiner Freundin.
>> DANIEL: Ja.
>> SALLY: Vorsicht, heiß!
So.
>> DANIEL: Ich müsste lügen.
Ich müsste jetzt echt lügen, wenn ich sagen würde,
es wäre nicht Minimum genauso gut.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> DANIEL: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oh.
Ich probiere das.
Ich esse nicht so gerne vor der Kamera.
>> DANIEL: Okay.
Hiermit bestätigt.
Willst du eine Punktzahl?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> DANIEL: 1 bis 10?
>> SALLY: Ja, wie?
Ihr Schwaben, ihr seid doch immer so geizig.
>> DANIEL: Sparsam, nicht geizig.
>> SALLY: Komm. Hau die Punkte raus.
Du bist im Badener Land.
>> DANIEL: 9,7.
>> SALLY: Oi!
Von 10?
>> DANIEL: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und 10 ist gut?
>> DANIEL: 10...
>> SALLY: Also sehr gut?
>> DANIEL: 10 wäre das Maximum. Ja. Ja. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ach, sehr gut!
Also schmeckt es?
>> DANIEL: Mega!
>> SALLY: Würdest du wahrscheinlich nicht nachmachen,
aber noch mal essen.
>> DANIEL: Ich glaube, ich könnte es
einfach nicht nachmachen. Das wäre das Problem.
Wollen schon, aber die Frage wäre halt,
ob man es hinbekommt.
>> SALLY: Ist ein sehr meditativer Vorgang.
Ja.
Also, wie gesagt,
könnt ihr das Rezept super vorbereiten.
Wenn ihr das jetzt tatsächlich zum Ramadan machen möchtet,
würde ich dazu empfehlen,
dass ihr das vielleicht so als Hauptspeise habt
und dann vorher vielleicht eine Suppe dazu habt
oder einen Salat noch dazu,
einfach was Leichtes, Warmes für den Magen.
Und dann eben so eine teigige, fleischige Hauptspeise.
Ja, komm. Davon kann man schon nicht so viel essen.
>> DANIEL: Nee, ich schon.
>> SALLY: Ich finde schon. So Salat dazu oder eine Suppe.
Probiert das Rezept gerne mal aus.
Auf Sallys-Blog.de findet ihr es
und natürlich auch in der App.
Die ist übrigens kostenlos.
>> DANIEL: Echt?
>> SALLY: Ja!
>> DANIEL: Also runterladen!
>> SALLY: Zehnmal!
>> DANIEL: Ich esse dann weiter, bevor wir jetzt hier abdriften
über meine Herkunft hier.
>> SALLY: Also bis zum nächsten Mal! Tschüss!
[Musik]